1 la parole est à monsieur pierre morel
à l'huissier merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse aux ministres
agriculture mais c'est stéphane le foll
monsieur le ministre
les agriculteurs se meurt et la france
regarde ailleurs
être agriculteur aujourd'hui c'est
travailler sept jours sur sept sans
compter ses heures
et perdre de l'argent être agriculteur
aujourd'hui en france c'est vivre dans
l'angoissé permanente de la faillite
c'est aussi par conséquent avoir un
risque de suicide multiplié par trois
par rapport aux autres catégories
socioprofessionnelles les agriculteurs
éleveurs de bovins de porcs producteurs
de lait de fruits et légumes et d'autres
sont étranglés par la chute des prix qui
ne leur permet pas de couvrir leurs
coûts de production et vos appels
désespérément à l'aide depuis des mois
manifestant a partout avec des
opérations coup de poing à caen au mont
saint michel à bruxelles à paris et dans
de nombreuses zones rurales et de
montagne
le fond du problème vous l'avez dit ici
mais monsieur le ministre la semaine
dernière c'est la question des prix
pourquoi l'écart continue-t-il de se
creuser entre les prix de vente
dérisoire des agriculteurs et les prix
toujours plus élevées que payent les
consommateurs finaux au supermarché
en septembre dernier une réponse à la
manifestation des détracteurs à paris
qui avait été largement soutenu par la
population française le premier ministre
avait annoncé un plan pour soutenir les
agriculteurs mais force est de constater
que le compte n'y est pas ni dans la loi
de finances pour 2016
ni dans la loi de finances rectificative
pour 2015 certes quelques réponses ont
été apportées dans l'urgence mais il
faut faire plus que poser un pansement
pour stopper l'hémorragie et les
agriculteurs attendent des réponses
structurelles de moyen et long terme
pour redonner du souffle à leur
exploitation qui doivent porter non
seulement sur les prix mais également
sur le niveau de charge sur la
simplification des normes et la
recherche d'innovation quelles garanties
pouvez vous donner aux agriculteurs
français pour qu'ils ne se sentent plus
oublié merci monsieur morel à l'huissier
l'appareil de monsieur le ministre